let me tell you something i love obscure
scams so much more than mainstream ones
i mean
i know a lot of people love hearing
about how bad dan bilzerian is but for
me
even if it doesn't get as many clicks my
favorite topics i love talking about are
scams that you never have heard of that
you would have never imagined are
happening right under your nose
and today we're talking about one of
those now we're gonna have to remove the
hat today because
this is not the time for joking around
okay silly fun time is over
because today we're talking about
lawyers who pimp out disabled people for
profit
now i know you're saying yourself
stephen you know i never heard of this
what are you talking about do you mean
sexually no okay no get your mind out of
the gutter
they're pimping disabled people out to
sue small businesses for profit
but while the disabled person gets
almost nothing from this exchange
lawyers are raking in millions of
dollars
in legal fees and before we go further
let me say
clearly i'm not criticizing the
americans with disabilities act it's an
important federal law
that says we need to provide equal
access to people with disabilities
i totally agree i'm also not criticizing
disabled people or lawyers who are in
good faith trying to use this law to get
equal access
but there are organizations out there
who claim to be working for equal access
but they seem to more be working for a
cash grab which doesn't just hurt the
businesses they sue
they're giving disabled people a bad
name in the eyes of the community so
with that caveat out of the way let's
explore the wild world of
ada abusive lawsuits and the disabled
people who are being pimped out by the
lawyers who siphon off all the profits
how much money have you gotten so far i
only get fifty dollars
from the lawsuit from each lawsuit from
each lawsuit
meet alyssa carton she's disabled and
she recently filed 99 lawsuits in new
mexico against small businesses
claiming they weren't providing equal
access but
here's the catch she never actually went
to the businesses she's suing as local
news koat reports
in the case of room's nursery alyssa
says she didn't go inside
something the owner of the nursery told
us too nobody recalls her
nobody alyssa carton is one of many
disabled people
hired to do something called drive-by
lawsuits these are lawsuits which are
filed by the hundreds
where a disabled person gets in a van
and usually just drives down the road
looking for any accessibility issue to
sue over with one goal in mind
settlements from the businesses sued
fox9 reports that
these lawsuits are often served with
immediate settlement offers
typically the lawsuits are served on a
business with an offer to settle
for between thirty five hundred to eight
thousand dollars
but while thousands of dollars may seem
expensive the alternative actually
fighting the case is usually worse even
if you win the legal bill is often more
than the settlement would have been
candyland rolled the dice and ended up
with a fourteen thousand dollar legal
bill
so for a principal you actually ended up
paying fifteen 15 000
but if you're thinking to yourself that
maybe these lawsuits are really just
about fast-paced change
think again many stores who paid out
settlements report that
no actual changes to their stores were
required or ever checked
simply paying the hush money was enough
the settlements didn't require any
repairs
that tells me that these lawsuits are
not about what we claim that they're
about
are they about accessibility for folks
with disabilities
or are they extortion which is it
lawyers are hiring out disabled people
driving them downtown and suing hundreds
of businesses out of time not because
they visit the stores but for ridiculous
reasons like tiny compliance issues
this was ground zero for the technical
issues he said he easily would have
fixed if a person with disabilities had
bothered to strike up a conversation
with him
instead of filing litigation over things
like the toilet paper dispenser which
was off by a few inches
like the urinal which was a few inches
too high and the businesses sued have
two options
settle and pay a few thousand dollars or
fight it and end up paying up to five
figures in legal fees and look this is a
complicated issue
for the disabled people who are involved
who rightfully want
disability access and often believe
they're getting into something honorable
alyssa carton who we met earlier said
she answered a craigslist ad mentioning
civil rights
they said they were looking for somebody
who cared about ada
but in many of these cases things look
less like civil rights and more like a
shakedown
in some the plaintiff who claims to be
disabled is later found
on camera actually to be walking take
for instance this man
who's supposed to be using a walker this
is gerald boytnut
boytnott's name is on 31 separate
lawsuits we watched one day as he
carried his walker
up a flight of icy steps to his home he
could walk again
absolutely incredible what an ada
lawsuit will do for you again walking
out and he's not even the only one
a well-known group who serially sues
local businesses is called
aid advocates for individuals with
disabilities and they just hired this
man
david ritzenthaler he's on hundreds of
lawsuits for eight but arizona reporter
dave biscobing found some holes in his
story
firstly was his claim of not making
money from the organization that hired
him
i get not a cent his lawyer peter
struejnik has a different story does he
get paid anything for this
yes how come your lawyer said he gives
you money they do not give me money
either 100 or 75 goes to ritz inhaler
not only that david ritzenthaler has
another secret he claims to have a
disability walking it's not easy to get
up and out of my chair how do you get
around as a cane
and well i hope it's with a cane bad
days i'm in a wheelchair but later
surprise surprise he seems to be walking
just fine david
also one other thing uh how long you
been walking without a cane
it's another absolute miracle he can
walk although he gets testy when dave
asks about his walker
i don't walk more in a pot in fact
i don't have this one i carry a cane in
the car with me just because
not today i don't have it in here today
now as a reminder that is a small clip
from a full investigation by dave
biscuit
please go watch it local investigative
news really doesn't get enough credit
and i won't give the whole thing away
but
let's just say that wasn't the only time
david ritzenthaler was found to be
walking
now what's the point of all this is it
that the ada is bad
no obviously not it's the lawyers who
are abusing the true purpose of it that
are the problem
and honestly some courts are getting fed
up recently peter storchnick the
notorious lawyer behind david
ritzenthaler was
disbarred and that would have made a
really tidy end to the story the good
guys finally winning and the bad lawyer
getting sanctioned and eventually
disbarred
but the truth is really that neat
because recently strojnic
is back once again filing lawsuits
not for other people because remember he
isn't a lawyer anymore he's filing
wait for it on behalf of himself
and he's filing these lawsuits by the
hundreds this time though
there's no investigative journalist
who's done the work to guide us
so i did some taking personally to find
out what's going on
and what i found will shock you find out
next time
on coffee zolo
[Music]
it's not easy to get up and out of my
of chair while your honey ends up